[Laughter]
yes BAM
shut through the heart and some random
gangster I don't know he's to blame damn
[Laughter]
know who's responsible for this it was
me
typical shit eat these typical shit
pre-orders through the roof baby they
did terrible things to me in this
I went in too hard I wanted to heart
Abel I don't know it's just me bad
except it is that manipul to stop the
kid from performing to evil crime a
child murder how my performing child
murder can't we take off the cost thank
you that is so disturbing so tell me
about yourself
I'm Domino my foul tell me what you
found you
well I was surprised to find a toy horse
with genitalia look at that
what the hell it's a unicorn do you mean
that says I did unicorns don't have
Jenna
[Laughter]
actually don't know how to do the okay
okay okay I lost it again my god you
sacrificed yourself for me well at least
I gave up mid-sentence one more on that
just after I gave up that's a good idea
trust me this isn't that good
yeah it kind of sucks how often you got
to feed that thing oh he gets hungry
every now and then
does he I'm not sure he likes it though
how much would you say mr. handy mr.
candy doesn't feel so good y'all are
cool but that thing's nasty oh how does
it poop
well that's complicated don't ask him
that I think an answer is fine well you
see when it enters tot
[Laughter]
you